first I'm curious because I know that
things evolve along the way when you
make a movie like this what is the
biggest difference between how you
pictured Superfly turning out when you
first accepted the role and how the
character is in the finished feature oh
you know when I just seen when I seen
the character and they sent me like you
know just kind of a 3D image of Superfly
like I knew it was gonna be crazy but
when you actually see it come together
you just can't imagine you know how cool
it is it's like the cool factors on like
a thousand so
um you know you just pinch yourself and
say you know I'm glad to be a part of
something this big and it's epic and um
I knew it would be you know dealing with
Seth and
Jeff and Kyle so yeah I always got a lot
of faith in that team and they
definitely don't disappoint here so I
know the recording process on this movie
was a little unique so what is something
about the way you did your voice
recording on this film versus past
animation opportunities that you hope to
see on future animated projects you work
on in the future well you know we were
in the room together
um I think it's important
to try to get as many actors together
that makes sense uh you know I did a lot
of my scenes straight with the with the
turtles you know so the guys were in the
room with me and um you can hear that
you can feel that in the movie if you
look at other animations sometimes you
can tell that it's
single
singly recorded but here you could feel
the the flavor of all of us in the same
room makes all the difference in the
world
be a scheduling challenge but based on
this finished product it seems well
worth trying to tackle that yeah I mean
schedule and challenge okay I I guess
you know but I've been to uh plenty
movies and we've had you know a read
through of the script and it seems like
you can get a lot of actors in there but
I guess for multiple uh sessions but at
least one let's try to get as many as
you can and go through the script I like
that approach I like that approach uh so
having done some of your recording with
the four young actors who play the
turtles can you give me an example of a
time when maybe one of them improv
something that kept you on your toes and
inspired you to do something with your
own performance that you didn't expect
well I mean they all were
kind of blurt now things and repeat me
in a way you know where they would uh
you know if I say uh you know I'm a
Molly you and they would be like oh
man I want to get Molly so you you
have to you would have to listen for
those things so you could catch them in
case they say something you know out of
line a Superfly had to check that you
know so they kept me on my toes the
energy was was high and um it just kept
building and we could add live and have
fun and we could do no wrong you know
they never told us wait a minute that
don't work you know they was like can we
get another one with all that ad-lib
been going on can you maybe pinpoint
like either like a particular line or
something you did with the character
that wasn't on the page that people
should keep an eye out for in the
finished film now six in the morning
police at my dough
you know I mean that's a shout out to
iced tea uh you know that's just a
famous hardcore hip-hop line uh that uh
was perfect when you whenever you kick
in the dough very much belonged in this
movie so now with superfly's whole
agenda here I imagine a lot of this is
on the page in the script and I'm pure
I'm curious if you can enhance this
through your performance as well what is
it like making sure that the audience
doesn't just view him as like a bad guy
doing bad things but a bad guy doing bad
things with purpose where maybe we don't
like back his plan but we understand why
he's doing that plan yeah you know
Superfly he's a guy he's a super villain
but he he's a sensitive guy he wants to
be accepted he know he's not he's not
the prettiest but he trust fly you know
what I mean you know how to dress so he
just want to be accepted like everybody
else by regular normal people we might
want to go to you know happy hour you
know what I'm saying have a
all the sugar and a beer you know I'm
saying cigar
chill you know uh call home see how the
maggots are doing and uh you know make
sure everything is all right what's
wrong with that it would have a bowl of
sugar and a beer with Superfly any day
now you have food on my brain so I'll
ask you something that I uh posed to the
four of them as well what is your
version of the Ninja Turtles Pizza like
the specific food you could eat all day
every day in any variation imaginable oh
this oh man give me
um you know I mean my version would be
you know I'll put pastrami on there I'll
put olives I'll put
mushrooms
uh I'll put uh
Chicken on there I'll put a a ribeye
steak and I'll add you know baked potato
you know we put some macaroni and cheese
on that thing you know I mean hit it off
with some spaghetti on the side you're
hitting every food group on a pizza now
I mean we ain't got the tacos and our
burritos I have a double cheeseburger on
there you know what I'm saying with an
egg on it you know what I mean and uh
put some chili on that thing and let's
have it you got it covered I was boring
and I'm like I'll eat a peanut butter
sandwich in any which way with anything
on it that's more exciting if one
unrelated thing before I wrap here that
I want to suggest because you're wearing
the shirt right now I think you need to
make a big three movie without a doubt
you know uh maybe we'll kidnap somebody
likes uh Steph Curry and and and make
him play in The Big Three I'll follow
that up let's say you made An Origin
movie about the big three what is like
one key element that you think would
wind up being the heart of that movie
that you would want to make sure
everyone out there whether they're
watching it now or not experiences the
moment I decided to
go ahead with the big three is the
moment
that Kobe Bryant scored 60 points in his
last game
and I wasn't there
I almost cried I did cry
that's that I think that got to be in it
okay I wasn't there I was working
I wasn't there
how could I forgive myself
I had to start the pick three